Ce samedi sur RFI Éco
d'ailleurs, La République
Démocratique du Congo est à
quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle. Comment va son
économie fragile et dépendante
des fluctuations monétaires?
Comment permettre son
développement en offrant à la
population les services de base
comme l'électricité, plusieurs
responsables congolais
répondent à nos questions.
Écodissi. Éco d'ailleurs, avec
la BOAD. Coupes les samedis à
dix heures dix TU sur RFI.
Rfi et
France 24 présentent
Radio Foot International, le
Café des sports, Annie Gasnier.
Bonjour à tous et merci de nous
rejoindre dans ce Café des
sports hebdomadaires, vous en
avez pris l'habitude, alors
aucune excuse pour ne pas être
là puisque vous pouvez nous
entendre grâce à votre
transistor, à votre post radio
et aussi grâce au Facebook live
sur internet et puis sur France
24 et tout le week-end voire
les autres jours vous pouvez
nous regarder aussi euh, sur
notre page Facebook. Alors, les
invités du jour ils sont aussi
très fidèles à notre émission
et très fidèles au vendredi.
Bonjour Rémy. Bonjour Annie.
Rémy extrêmement élégant. Ah.
Du bleu euh boutons qui
brillent. Mais parce que hier
euh j'étais en train de fêter
justement 10 ans de
consécration à l'église, vous
étiez là. Le mariage. Votre
mariage euh c'était dans le 7e
arrondissement à Paris. Et nous
étions un petit nombre de RFI à
y être. Eh bien félicitations
Rémy à vous et à votre épouse.
Bonjour Xavier Barret et Xavier
Xavier aussi bien sûr. Bien
sûr. Il y avait un très beau un
chanteur magnifique. Ouais.
C'était très un choriste
franco-camernais. Euh je me
souviens exceptionnel. Oui il y
avait il y avait beaucoup de
turnes enfin. Il y avait quand
même déjà la vie oh ça c'était
Ready Congrès et Xavier
C'est des noces de quoi Rémy
les dix ans, coton euh des
noces de N Gono Bonjour Annie.
Vous êtes là euh pour euh
éclairer les débats entre nos
deux habitués hein euh et un
peu parfois les les partager et
puis Frédéric Sutaud lui il est
là notamment pour écouter tous
nos auditeurs et internautes,
bonjour. Bonjour euh Annie,
bonjour tout le monde et
bonjour tonton Rémy nous dit
Marcel Marcellus. Je sais pas
s'il était invité lui il y a
dix ans. Il a été porté. Alors
dans les débats du jour, eh
bien euh nous parlerons d'un
prix qui revient avec le
printemps, vous en avez pris
l'habitude, le prix Marc Vivien
Foé avec son onze type. Ils
sont bien 11 joueurs à
prétendre cette euh saison au
titre de meilleur joueur
africain de la Ligue 1 qui est
euh ou qui sont les favoris de
cette édition 20vingt-trois.
Nous vous en parlerons. Un
nouvel échec du football
français sur la scène
européenne hier soir, l'OGC
Nice a été éliminé par le FC
Bâle et la Ligue 1 pourrait
sortir du top 5 des
championnats européens.
Pourquoi les clubs français ne
progressent pas? Quels
solutions apporter de crampons?
Les affiches à travers l'Europe
euh, au cours du week-end, nous
avons retenu la rencontre
Juventus Naples entre le
premier et désormais le
troisième d'Italie puisque les
Bianco Nelly ont temporairement
récupéré 15 points euh, les 15
points qui les avaient
sanctionnés. Et puis dans
l'Hexagone il y a des chocs en
perspective pour les places
européennes et nous aurons un
Xavier entre l'OL et l'OM et
puis un Lens Monaco c'est match
qui promet être il y aura vos
cartons et les nôtres. au
générique de l'émission David
Finzel m'a aidé à préparer
l'émission avec Pierre Guérin,
à la réalisation il est revenu,
Laurence Alerno est là euh pour
euh la réalisation radio, pour
ce qui est de la vidéo, et Yann
Bourdelas sont eux aussi
fidèles au poste. Le Café des
sports, les débats sont
ouverts.
Ambassadeur du ministère au
Cameroun
Le 11 du quinzième Prix Marc
Vivien Foé est donc euh établi,
rendu public euh dans
l'émission de lundi pour ceux
qui nous sont le plus fidèles.
Euh alors je Frédéric on va le
rappeler hein aujourd'hui parce
que finalement euh pour ceux
qui euh n'étaient pas là, qui
auraient pu oublier. On va vous
rappeler euh les noms de ces 11
joueurs, à noter euh précision
qu'il y a quatre défenseurs.
Alors c'est pas si euh commun
euh qu'il y ait autant de
défenseurs que d'attaquants. Il
y a neuf nationalités
représentées. Frédéric, à vous
euh Xavier défenseur marocain
de Reims. Il y a aussi euh
Salis Abdul Samed euh lensois
du Ghana. Mama Baldé, attaquant
Guy et Bissault Guinée est un
de de trois. Mohamed Kamara lui
de Monaco il est malien. Habib
Diallo, sénégalais, Strasbourg
euh attaquant. Notre lauréat de
l'an dernier c'est que Fofana,
le Lensois, il est Xavier. . Le
défenseur du PSG, Ashrakimi, le
marocain, qui a joué la Coupe
du monde. Il y a chancel Memba,
le défenseur euh de l'OM, il
est euh de la RADIO T'es
l'attaquant de Nice Nigérian.
Marshall euh Mounetti, il est
rémoi et il vient du Zimbabwe.
Il doit nous en rester un à
Marie Traoré, le défenseur
malien de Rennes. Exactement,
alors une belle liste qui euh
je pense tout au long de la
semaine euh tous ceux qui ont
été consultés dans notre
studio, le confirmer. Il y a un
suspense. Bien sûr, il y a des
favoris qui se dégagent et euh
moi j'aimerais vous vous poser
la question. Rémy selon vous,
qui pour succéder à ces
d'ailleurs, est-ce que c'est
euh peut se à lui-même. Je vous
dis pas de nous avouer
spécialement votre vote si vous
voulez y garder secret mais en
tout cas euh, quel est votre
regard sur cette liste? Je vais
pas dire que il y a pas de
camerounais je suis désolée.
Mais je crois que c'est que
Fofana hum alterne cette
fois-ci le bon et le moins bon.
C'est-à-dire que il peut
succéder à lui-même, on a vu
qu'il a des bonnes prestations
lorsqu'il s'agit de trouver
véritablement aussi d'autres
cadors. C'est là où il vient
mais j'ai prestations qui n'ont
pas été assez confortables.
Mais cependant je crois que
parce qu'on privilégie toujours
euh les milieux de terrain ou
les défenseurs. Moi je crois
que cette le milieu de terrain
ou les attaquants, moi je vais
privilégier cette fois-ci un
défenseur. C'est-à-dire chancel
Bemba. Parce que je constate
que Chancel Bemba même s'il a
connu un petit temps de mou
mais au niveau de l'OM qui
quand même est en train d'être
juste aujourd'hui une équipe
pratiquement européenne. On se
rend quand même compte qu'il a
apporté une certaine hargne et
surtout il est ce défenseur qui
est capable de marquer parce
que sur les 39 buts auxquels et
la plupart il a quand même
inscrit six buts. On sait qu'il
y a des attaquants qui ne sont
pas capables d'inscrire autant.
Donc euh bien sûr également je
pourrais prendre euh quelqu'un
qui est dans un club qui est en
difficulté, le Strasbourg est
là Marc quand même 15 buts. Oui
dans tout le palmarès de Xavier
à mon avis hein je donne mes
mes mes trois. Donc je peux
trouver que lui également il
mérite euh qu'il puisse être à
ce sommet-là parce que être
parmi les médiocres et réussir
à faire ce qu'il a fait, cela
veut dire qu'il est
exceptionnel. Euh Xavier Oui
moi l'an dernier j'avais voté
pour Amary Traoré parce que je
trouve qu'il avait fait une
saison Xavier avec Rennes dont
il est le capitaine d'ailleurs.
Il avait failli qualifier le
Mali et à l'époque euh ils
étaient encore en course pour
la la Coupe du monde. Euh voilà
alors été blessé cette année
euh, le le Mali s'est pas
qualifié pour la Coupe du monde
euh, c'est lui je trouve fait
une euh, saison Xavier et ça
m'étonnerait pas qu'il soit élu
une deuxième fois d'affilée
euh, je pense que un Marocain
mérite d'y être mais avec un
seul des deux qui était à la
Coupe du monde donc c'est
Hakimi et puis pour finir euh,
bah, je rejoins un peu ça
m'arrive de temps en temps mais
je rejoins un peu Rémy Gono sur
euh, le cas de chancel même
bah, je trouve qu'il fait une
très très belle saison à avec
l'OM donc euh, si on s'en tient
aux critères ligue un bah, on
retrouve les trois premiers du
championnat euh, Hakimi PSG
c'est Lens et euh, Chancel
Mbemba O Un peu de miel pour
vos oreilles euh j'ai mal au
coeur j'ai mal au coeur, je je
suis tombé dans les pommes
excusez-moi. Oui oui non non
mais euh je je rejoins Rémy euh
pour moi j'installe à crever
l'écran cette saison, il a été
important, d'ailleurs son
retour face à Troyes a fait la
différence, on sait que quand
il est pas là, la défense
marseillaise n'est absolument
pas la même, après moi je pense
que le deuxième sera pour moi
encore un défenseur parce que
les défenseurs ont fait cette
saison ont été très bons. Il y
en a un qui est à Reims, qui
est très intéressant, c'est
Abdella qui fait une très
grosse saison mais
rappelez-vous la saison passée
il a failli s'à ses côtés on
dit oui il est bon parce que
Face est là il est parti en
Angleterre ça fonctionne pas
lui il a tenu la baraque il a
été exceptionnel et mon
troisième choix ça peut être
moi un attaquant qui marque pas
mal de buts ou alors ça peut
être un milieu de terrain jeune
qui a de l'expérience donc euh
hein? C'est ça va le suspense.
Ouais ça ça va être mais mais
pour moi euh Abdelhamid est
chancel sont les deux au même
niveau alors il y en aura qu'un
mais les deux ont été très très
très bons mais pour moi il y a
pas forcément euh Hakimi qui se
trouve dans Sète parce qu'il
aurait dû prouver beaucoup plus
et c'est que Fofana je pense
que c'est la saison, c'est pas
dans trop. C'est juste que on
l'a moins vu. Et il y a un
joueur qui joue à ses côtés,
qui est pas mal, qui peut être
troisième et qui a apporté
énormément. Hum. Eh oui, qui a
apporté énormément, et lui on
l'a on l'a donc et du coup
c'est euh intéressant ce que
dit Marc Libbra parce qu'il
rejoint ce qu'a dit Franck
Simon l'autre jour présenté la
liste lundi avec Christophe
Jousset euh il disait que lui
il n'aurait pas mis Hakimi dans
cette liste donc c'est vrai que
de de Ashrakimi parce que oui
parce que théoriquement c'est
le meilleur joueur africain de
ligue 1 c'est alors on sait
qu'il faut qu'il soit
international africain mais
après euh ce qu'ils ont fait à
la Coupe du monde ou pas euh
veut ne pas euh quand ils c'est
la Ligue 1 qu'on m'assure. Euh
Frédéric, est-ce que vous euh
avez alors vous nous avez euh
évidemment euh vous serez un
des votants hein puisque le le
jury je le rappelle à à tous
nos nos auditeurs et
téléspectateurs, c'est une
centaine de personnes et ce
sont tous ceux qui suivent la
Ligue 1 qui sont des
spécialistes et qui euh ont un
regard particulier sur le la
Ligue 1 et les joueurs euh
africains des effectifs. Non il
y a il y a un joueur dont on
n'a pas parlé, c'était Rémy
l'attaquant nigérian de de
Nice.
Il a pas réussi à qualifier les
les Niçois pour les
demi-finales de de la Ligue euh
Liga Conférence, mais il a
quand même lui aussi fait une
euh une très bonne saison. Euh
moi je m'en remets aux
téléspectateurs, aux auditeurs
hein. première partie de
saison. Là on a des drapeaux
sénégalais de sortie un
attaquant quand même, je crois
qu'il a marqué sept buts en
douze matchs hein. Il a été
très bon avec le Royaume-Uni.
Avec Lorient et avec Nice. Ça
peut faire un un bon score
comme Diallo. Donc les deux se
se tiennent tu vois? Ouais.
Mais si on fait remonter un peu
les les réactions, il y en a
beaucoup pour Habib Galop hein
euh Rémy là je crois que vous
avez visé juste hein euh Rémy
tu peux venir habiter au
Sénégal euh Barsaïdix non mais
sinon c'est c'est pour Xavier à
coeur ouvert pour chancel Bemba
nous dit euh Maxime Wing je
soutiens la présence de mon
compatriote, Delphin euh
Taraboucha donc euh chancelle
ou ou Habib euh Diallo
peut-être hein. Alors euh ça
sera la 15e édition de ce Prix
Marc Vivien Foé et vous le
savez au tout début de de cette
euh de ce prix Marc il y en
avait eu un qui avait reçu deux
fois, consécutivement le titre,
c'était Gervinho à l'époque et
donc il y a pour l'instant
Xavier est-ce que euh j'avais
une question tiens pour le
joueur, pour euh l'ancien
joueur euh Marc Libbra , est-ce
que selon vous ce prix est
rentré euh est est un hum un
marqueur euh dans les
curriculums euh vitas des et
des joueurs, dans les CV des
joueurs. Est-ce que selon vous
il a il a déjà acquis ces ces
lettres de noblesse? On voit
que par exemple les clubs
communiquent lors du du
lancement de la liste,
automatiquement ils mais
d'avoir un joueur qui a
apporté, regardez à Lens on en
a parlé, que ça soit euh à à
Rennes, que ça soit euh
Gervignolet on on est enfin on
est obligé d'en parler. Parce
que c'est important, ça
représente l'Afrique, l'Afrique
est un continent immensissime,
donc on est en France, quand on
arrive à décrocher, je pense
qu'il y a pas mal de gamins
quand ils sont en centre de
formation, ils ont été un petit
peu bercés par RFI, par ce qui
se passe, et ils voient leur
grand frère, parce qu'ils
appellent ça des grands frères,
ben un jour, peut-être que je
vais le gagner. Donc oui, c'est
important, c'est rentrer. On ne
peut plus dire aujourd'hui
après la 15e édition, oui,
c'est un petit coup d'essai,
non, c'est pas un coup d'essai.
Et je sais qu'il y en a plein.
Mais bien sûr et il y en a qui
sont là en se disant j'aimerais
bien l'avoir, parce que il y en
a quand on va dans les clubs, à
moi, tu sais, je l'ai pas eu.
Ah, t'as t'as vos t'avais voté
pour moi ou pas? Écoute, je
sais pas, si j'ai voté pour toi
en tout cas, voilà, tu fais
partie des meilleurs Africains
français. Parce que il y en il
y en a d'autres qui peuvent
arriver mais voilà, c'est pour
ça que moi le troisième ça peut
être euh euh souvent le l'année
prochaine on peut il faut qu'il
confirme pour les deux premiers
pour moi sont toujours très
importants et influents. Et
moi, le troisième, je mets
toujours quelqu'un pour
l'encourager. Comme j'avais
fait la saison passée aussi,
donc ça c'est plutôt
intéressant il y a une grande
adhésion déjà de de nos
auditeurs qui donnent toujours
prompt à donner leur leur avis
et leur classement et puis vous
euh vous votez, vous en avez
l'habitude euh Xavier Xavier,
Rémy et Frédéric. Alors on
continue et on va parler
football, on va parler coupes
européennes.
C'est terminé, c'est fini, Nice
est éliminé de la Ligue Europa
conférence, il n'y a plus de
clubs français. Nous avons donc
les affiches des euh,
demi-finalistes des trois
coupes européennes existants
actuellement et les clubs
italiens, ça ne vous aura pas
échappé, se taille la part du
lion, on en avait déjà parlé
hier avec Matteo puisque on est
sûr qu'il y aura un mille
années en finale de la Ligue
des champions, ils sont encore
deux en demi-finale, mais
d'autres clubs italiens se sont
donc qualifiés hier soir, ils
sont au nombre de cinq. Dans
toutes ces équipes, il y a
aussi beaucoup de joueurs
français On a Karim Benzema, on
a Olivier Giroud, on a Adrien
Rabiot, on a aussi Jean-Kévin
Augustin au Kurt Zuma. Mais
comme d'habitude, nous n'avons
pas de clubs français dans ce
niveau de la compétition. L'OGC
Nice qui portait tellement les
espoirs hier du euh football
français, eh bien en dépit de
son parcours étonnant,
encourageant, a été éliminé,
sorti par le FC Bâle, en plus
sur sa pelouse de Nice. Triste
soirée, donc, faut dire que
rien n'allait trop cette soirée
parce qu'on a vu par exemple
que les supporters hein qui
étaient venus euh de Suisse eh
ben au dernier moment il y a eu
un arrêté préfectoral, ils ont
été interdit, ils ont été
refoulés donc c'était dommage
parce qu'ils auraient bien aimé
euh participer à la fête et
puis bon après il y a peut-être
euh la composition de l'équipe
qui en a surpris certains,
Didier Digar, c'est sans doute
trompé, il l'a reconnu
d'ailleurs. Un échec donc qui
en suit d'autres, six équipes
étaient en piste, je le
rappelle en début de saison.
Les équipes se battent pour se
qualifier. Saison et patatras.
Est-ce que euh vous comprenez
pourquoi euh Marc Libra euh,
finalement à chaque fois on se
dit allez euh, il faut la place
européenne, la place européenne
on se bat pour ça, on gagne la
Coupe de France pour ça et puis
alors parfois on a l'impression
que les équipes en à
l'intersaison changent
tellement que finalement elles
sont absolument pas
compétitives ou alors euh,
elles tiennent pas la la
distance. Je je ne sais pas si
elles tiennent pas la distance,
c'est vrai que les équipes font
le maximum, on en parle
actuellement, on veut l'Europe,
on veut l'Europe, le problème
c'est qu'une fois qu'on a
l'Europe, à partir du mois de
septembre on commence à dire ah
mais le ring, il faut jouer le
jeudi, il faut jouer le
mercredi à ce qu'on peut
décaler le match, on cherche
toujours des puis après il y a
une chose qui est assez
impressionnante, on l'a vu sur
l'exemple euh de Bal, c'est que
quand le tirage au sort est
fait balle, Nice et la plupart
des journalistes, des
consultants s'intéressent à la
FOOT donc si on passe la FOOT
ça sera la finale ouverte. Euh
moi j'étais à Bal, j'ai
commenté le match, euh la
plupart des supporters euh ça
donne quoi cette année? Non
mais attendez, il faut déjà
jouer balle. Oui mais balle, ça
fait dix, 12 ans qu'on les voit
plus, ça n'existe pas, mais
balle a un grand passé. Au
niveau européen, ce qu'on
n'avait pas Nice et
malheureusement, on se la, on
se la totalement, on se la
joue. On pense que, on imagine
que le problème c'est que il
faut les jouer les matchs. Et
on nous on le, nous, on est les
rois, les Français, on est les
meilleurs du monde, on sait
tout faire, mais on passe
jamais les tours. Faut pas s'en
prendre quà Nice. C'est c'est
Paris, c'est Marseille, c'est
c'est c'est Monaco, c'est tous
ces clubs-là qui sont tristes
records ces clubs-là. Mais
quand Nice a la solution euh à
balle, il mène, ils font la
différence, ils se font
rattraper. De deux, hier ils
mènent un zéro, ils arrivent
pas à faire la différence parce
que ce but arrive rapidement,
c'est la fête, on chante,
tendance, ouais c'est super,
mais il faut le jouer le match,
il faut le jouer. Et à
l'arrivée, ça fait deux à 1 et
on passe un peu pour des
imbéciles et c'est ça qui est
dommage, c'est que on joue
toujours les matchs avant et on
pense qu'on est les plus forts.
Je vais vous faire un petit
rappel quand Unai Emery signe
la plupart on dit mais c'est
qui cet entraîneur, il a jamais
rien fait, rien quà lui, il a
plus de Coupe d'Europe que nous
tous les clubs français réunis.
C'était juste pour faire ça. Et
à l'époque j'avais dit ça, on
me dit, ouais mais il est pas
sérieux pour rentrer les paris.
Il est pas sérieux, mais à lui
tout seul il gagne plus de
Coupe d'Europe que que tous les
clubs Xavier euh d'une façon
générale hein on on pense à
d'autres euh à d'autres
saisons, je me souviens de
Lille euh une année qui avait
fait je crois zéro point euh il
y a ou un point. Il y a il y a
on a l'impression que euh il y
a comme un est-ce qu'il y a un
complexe euh ou alors euh trop
beau? Il faut je rejoins parce
qu'il faut quand même
différencier ceux qui jouent la
Ligue des champions et on s'est
moqué de l'OM mais ils étaient
en Ligue des champions cette
année, on sait que vraiment le
niveau est extrêmement élevé,
de ceux qui jouent les autres
coupes européennes et là bon
euh vous vous faisiez allusion
au vainqueur de la Je crois que
le FC Nantes, le le parcours
qu'il a fait était totalement
inespéré. En revanche, Monaco
et Rennes, là c'est un vrai
scandale. Monaco ils auraient
dû être en Ligue des champions.
Déjà ils se renaît ça fait deux
ans déjà. Ils se font à chaque
fois avoir un barrage, ils se
retrouvent en Ligue Europa, et
là ils se font éliminer aux
tirs au but alors qu'ils
avaient d'ailleurs gagné le
match aller. Euh non mais
Monaco c'est un scandale,
Rennes c'est une vraie
déception, euh alors après on
tombe sur Nice parce que c'est
les derniers qui sont là. Mais
franchement euh c'est leur
mettre une grosse
responsabilité parce que euh
qu'il faut une saison pas
terrible. Ouais. Et et de les
retrouver là comme dernier
espoir du football français,
c'est un malheureux concours de
circonstances. Mais il y a des
équipes à commencer par Monaco
et Rennes qui eux n'ont pas
assuré du tout le rang qui est
le leur. Rémy était en Ligue
des champions il y a pas
longtemps Monaco euh à chaque
fois joue pour la Ligue des
champions et ils sont pas
capables de se qualifier pour
les quarts de finale de la
Ligue Europa. Là il y a une
vraie défaillance qui pénalise
le football français. Donc moi
j'épargne un petit peu Nice qui
va faire plaisir à notre ami
Patrick Juillard parce
qu'effectivement ils ont pas
été bons, ils ont raté la
marche, mais c'était à sur eux
que devaient retomber cette
responsabilité il y avait
d'autres équipes qui devaient
assurer mieux que ça
auparavant. Rémy quel est selon
vous la la raison de de ces
échecs euh successifs et
répétés euh est-ce que les
effectifs euh les
investissements ou alors
peut-être qu'il y a pas assez
de joueurs français puisque les
bons français finalement sont
dans les équipes qui euh qui
sont en quart de final comme
Rabiot ou comme euh Olivier
Giroud? Ou Benzema ou Kevin?
Attendez qui a battu hier?
C'est Kevin Augustin. Paris
Saint-Germain c'est une grosse
puissance financière et
d'ailleurs la dernière fois qui
marquait des buts encore contre
bon c'était euh Di Maria qui a
été rejetée au Paris
Saint-Germain, il était en
ligue un. C'est là où je
comprends pas parce que
aujourd'hui vous voulez parler
de ces équipes-là qui qui
doivent être excusées, ne
doivent pas être excusées.
selon vous. Parce que justement
la raison c'est quoi? C'est que
justement ce qu'on appelle en
France par exemple la formation
non seulement on se rend compte
aujourd'hui que ce n'est plus
la même chose mais même les
joueurs qu'on a on ne les
conserve pas parce que quand on
parle de formation je vous
prends par exemple je pense que
la France est pillée de ce
côté-là non? Ah oui mais
attendez il faut accepter on ne
vient pas on a jamais fait un
braquage sur une équipe de la
France donc à une certaine
période on se dit quand même
que en soixante-seize que
Saint-Etienne étant au même
niveau que Saint-Etienne avait
joué la Ligue des champions on
se dit quand même que oui mais
attends deux-mille-neuf je
prends bien deux-mille-huit
deux-mille-neuf on a revu
justement des jeunes de
Saint-Étienne qui étaient
encore en Ligue des champions
comment est-ce qu'on ne peut
pas comprendre toutes ces
choses-là que on peut faire
avec ce qu'on a en main au lieu
d'aller toujours chercher
parfois où il nous faut tel
joueur eh bien que celui-là
arrive vous le jetez et
exactement comme un on a vu ça
avec Toupotine qui venait
battre le Paris Saint-Germain
et il y a un problème africain
qui dit Xavier que tu as en
main pour tuer le serpent. Oh
là là. Frédéric. Ben non mais
le le grave problème là c'est
que ça arrive cette année mais
ça arrive en fait tous les ans.
C'est surtout ça hein. Marc euh
rappelait tout à l'heure les
deux victoires françaises en
Coupe d'Europe. Hein le l'OM en
Ligue des champions, le PSG en
Coupe des Coupes et il y a un
ratio aussi qui est
intéressant, je regardais, il y
a eu 14 finales de jouer pour
les clubs français, ils en ont
gagné que deux. Donc déjà on a
le le plus mauvais ratio. Quand
on arrive à final ce qui est
très rare, on les perd. Hein
les néerlandais? Même pas en
demi-finale. Le SG était en
l'OM a été en finale en 208, le
PSG a été en final en en
20vingt. Ouais. Donc euh ça
remonte pas, on remonte pas
jusqu'en
mille-neuf-cent-soixante-seize
comme Rémy Gono. Euh il y a eu
des clubs français en finale,
ils les ont pas gagnés,
d'accord, mais au moins ils
étaient en finale en
demi-finale, là on passe même
pas l'écart. Un Marc euh
du monde mais euh n'arrive pas
à je pense pas qu'il y ait de
complexe, c'est juste quà un
moment donné on se croise
supérieur aux autres, on le
voit dans tout ce qu'on est
capable de faire, on ne sait
plus gérer aujourd'hui des
supporters qui viennent, on ne
sait plus rien faire en ligue 1
pour moi et encore une fois
dans une préparation j'étais à
balle, on nous explique, la
plupart des gens nous
parlaient, ouais, la FOOT c'est
un bon tirage, mais on a même
pas joué Bal! Attention! Et que
ce soit tous les chroniqueurs,
toutes les euh terrible! C'est
que on nous explique, et Paris,
euh rappelez-vous, on nous
explique chaque fois, ah la
phase de poule, mais mais c'est
simple, mais ça va passer! Ah
bon, ça va passer deuxième!
Quand ils prennent le plus dur
et ils se font sortir. Et on
nous dit ah bah on est déçus,
mais jouez les matchs! Ben il y
en a beaucoup euh Prix, les
équipes françaises sont nulles
en Europe et Junior Kingo.
Junior Kimpo il nous dit, la
Ligue un, le niveau de la Ligue
un, c'est une ligue de fermiers
et de boulangers. Bon alors
c'est sûr? C'est c'est sûr que
la Ligue 1 en tout cas, on on
dit toujours qu'on est parmi
les cinq grands championnats
européens mais on est le
dernier des des cinq et et
notre place elle est elle est
un peu euh branlante. Puis on
est menacé, alors on a
longtemps été menacé par les
Portugais on serait menacé par
les Pays-Bas la France qui est
actuellement cinquième peut se
qui a plus de clubs donc en
dernier carré des trois coupes
européennes peut se faire
doubler par les Pays-Bas mais
les Pays-Bas n'ont plus quà
représenter la Zalkmar et pour
que les Pays-Bas passent devant
la France il faut classer
Dalkma gagne la finaliste la
coupe euh euh Europa
Conférence, la Ligue Europa
Conférence et qui gagne euh
tous leurs matchs en qu'ils en
gagnent au moins deux sur les 3
à jouer. Donc il y a peu de
chance que la France perde
cette cinquième place en
demi-finale, s'ils sortent West
Ham, ils sont en finalistes
mais bon à priori West Ham est
plus fort mais bon euh Xavier
a été en finale de la Coupe de
l'UFA à l'époque en
mille-neuf-cent-quatre-vingt-un
contre Ibswitch presque
soixante-sept. Voilà pour les
pour les plus anciens
C'est un club qui a aussi une
histoire on verra si cette
place euh des clubs français
est menacée mais en tout cas ça
pour euh la la conséquence
c'est qu'on a moins de place la
saison d'après euh en Europe.
On continue parce qu'il y a
aussi des matchs au cours du
week-end prochain et ça ça nous
intéresse.
Finaliste
La Juventus de Turin, de retour
en Série A et si je dis de
retour c'est parce qu'elle est
sur le podium depuis hier soir,
non, elle a pas joué de match,
si elle en a joué en Ligue
Europa et elle a même gagné
elle s'est même qualifiée, mais
surtout hier le club des
Bianconneries on vous en avait
longuement parlé hein, de ce
problème avec Matteo Choffie,
elle avait eu 15 points de
pénalité, c'était au mois de
janvier dernier, eh bien hier
temporairement euh c'est cette
punition infligée pour fraude
comptable présumée et l'enquête
est toujours en cours, eh bien
euh ils avaient donc euh
dégringolé au classement, mais
ils ne se sont pas laissés
abattre, ils ont à travailler
et les voilà donc troisième.
Ils vont se retrouver face à
l'équipe de Naples. Alors on
peut se dire peut-être que les
dynamiques sont complètement
différentes parce que on se
retrouve avec euh une équipe de
la Juventus eh bien qui s'est
qualifiée hier, qui en plus se
retrouve troisième et qui a
toujours des ambitions
européennes alors que Naples,
Naples vient de d'être éliminé
en quart de final c'était la
première fois qu'il le
disputait de leur histoire mais
en quart de finale de la Ligue
des champions et les napolitain
euh quand même toujours au euh
maintenant ils n'ont plus que
ça à jouer mais ils ont euh
quatorze points d'avance sur le
deuxième qu'est la Ladiodrome
et ils ont Xavier d'avance sur
la Juventus. Finalement euh
Xavier Barret se ce match. Le
napolitain avait gagné le match
aller cinq à un hein c'était
une drôle de correction euh et
on avait vu toute la la beauté
de du football de de Naples.
Est-ce que là on peut se dire
finalement ça va être un peu
une histoire d'ego euh la Juve
va vouloir montrer que euh
qu'elle renaît de ses cendres.
Clairement, clairement être un
match très intéressant, même si
Naples sera champion puisqu'ils
ont une telle avance que même
si ils restent mais euh le
problème pour Naples c'est que
aujourd'hui ils sont champions,
mais ils ont été incapables de
battre euh le cinquième du
championnat en trois
confrontations puisqu'ils ont
perdu en championnat contre
mille en 4 zéro là. Et en Ligue
des champions, ils ont perdu un
zéro le match aller, ils ont
fait un un en retour. Donc euh
quand même. Oui, mais bon, ils
ont pas été incapables de les
battre. Alors. Ils ont une
chose quand même, aussi même
n'était pas au match aller. De
ce quart de final et là il sera
là, il est revenu et c'est même
lui qui inscrit euh à l'arrache
et mes Zambos étaient suspendus
pour le pour le match retour,
mais bon euh ce Naples-là
finalement il il il aura ce
titre sur sa formidable phase
aller et depuis comme ça. Oui
ça arrive, mais là du coup
forcément la la la même s'il y
a une énorme attente à Naples
puisqu'ils ont plus été
champions depuis
neufcentquatre-vingt-dix, euh
ils sont champions mais ils ont
pas été capables de parachever
euh ce ce cette magnifique
saison avec un beau parcours
européen. Donc moi je que pour
eux effectivement le la façon
de finir c'est bien sûr d'aller
gagner à Turin, mais ce sera
compliqué parce que la Juve
veut euh veut aller en Coupe
d'Europe parce que
effectivement on leur a remis
les 15 points mais en fait
c'est juste une suspension de
la sanction qui avait été
temporaire. Voilà ils peuvent
quand même être euh le mois
prochain hein. On sait pas
parce que il y a aussi des
ramifications. Rémy on est
quand même assuré du spectacle.
Oui spectacle il y aura
d'autant plus que Naples est
quand même, euh je me souviens
ici nous étions avec qui a
réussi à se faufiler. Il nous
disait que l'équipe qui jouait
mieux en Ligue des champions
c'était Naples. Ouais. Il avait
même dit que Naples devait
gagner la Ligue des champions.
Moi je rigolais je disais
qu'attendait l'oreille.
Attendez L'Oréal donc euh et
bien évidemment aujourd'hui on
voit que Naples euh justement
ce que je disais il faut éviter
ça parce qu'ils avaient déjà
une certe une certaine
suffisance. Ils se disaient
qu'ils étaient Xavier
imperméable qui prenait
subitement on a vu qu'ils
étaient trop trop fragiles sur
le plan défensif. Bon, on peut
peut-être se dire que parce
qu'il manquait des éléments
clés, mais quand on regarde
quand même les dernières
prestations qu'ils ont livrées,
c'est vrai que ils auraient pu
passer, ils auraient pu passer
parce que quand on regarde le
match contre Milan Massé, ils
ont non seulement de la
possession, mais ils ont
beaucoup d'occasions qu'ils ont
eu à vendanger. Hum. Donc moi
je trouve quand même ce
napolitain consistant que cette
équipe euh qu'on est en train
de venir ressusciter enfin nous
sommes à Pâques, c'est-à-dire
que Jésus est ressuscité, la
Juve est aussi ressuscité, il
n'y a que l'OM que j'attends
maintenant parce qu'on va même
dire que perdu l'OM qui a perdu
et justement c'est au
championnat en
quatre-vingt-treize. On va nous
dire que non, l'OM également
aussi suite à une décision on
décide de remettre le le
trophée à l'ouest. Euh, Marc,
est-ce que quand même
finalement Naples ça vient
depuis tellement loin cette
équipe qui euh, remontait petit
à petit, qui s'essoufflait
souvent au même moment en
championnat et qui ne ne
reculait euh, largement au
classement euh flirter avec la
première place. Là c'était
peut-être même si on choisit
pas la compétition, là ils se
disent il y a quand même
presque le plus beau qui reste
c'est le Scudetto. Pour eux ça
reste le Graal euh je vous
trouve très dur parce que pour
moi Naples a fait une saison
exceptionnelle, je pensais que
Naples était capable d'aller
encore plus loin. Ouais. Quand
on voit les deux matchs
aller-retour face à l'AC Milan,
c'est exceptionnel que l'AC
Milan passe. Mike Megan les a
écs de début jusqu'à la
fin, qu'on le veuille ou non.
Et et ils sont capables de
cent, 150 buts, là ils ont tout
raté, mais il y a des moments
ou des matchs où vous passez à
travers. Sur ces matchs-là, ils
sont passés à travers. Donc je
suis d'accord mais même sans
parler du match de championnat
de championnat quand tu quand
tu 22 ou 23 points d'avance et
que tu as fait le travail, tu
as fait le taf. Après, Zambo
est pas là, qui n'est pas là.
Ozyme n'est pas là.
Excusez-moi, ça change vraiment
l'équipe. Et ils sont pas
passés loin de quand même de
créer l'exploit parce que s'il
y a quinze minutes de la fin
Mike Meng pas le penalty, je
pense qu'on vit vingt, 2-5
minutes de folie. Bon, c'est le
football, c'est comme ça. L'AC
Milan qui était la moins bonne
équipe est passée, mais cette
équipe de Naples, pour moi,
elle reste la meilleure et elle
va aller chercher ce Scoutetto
qu'elle attend depuis plus de
33 ans. C'est mérité. Et
c'était, oui, mais c'est
mérité, sur ce qu'il a fait,
sur l'ensemble d'aller chercher
le titre de de meilleur buteur.
Il réalise une une Xavier . En
tout cas, les téléspectateurs
ils sont derrière le Napoli
euh, Gino qui nous dit Napoli
un avantage certain, il les
voit gagner euh contre la Ju et
puis il y a Alfred euh Ganga
qui vous trouve un peu sévère
Xavier effectivement, Naples le
fait mieux que le PSG, il nous
rappelle hein cette année.
Annie de de remettre les quinze
points en attendant dans 15 ou
20 jours peut-être de les lever
ou mais c'est c'est n'importe
quoi, excusez-moi, c'est pas
possible. C'est non mais c'est
que d'un coup on 11 points de
plus finalement le championnat
est non mais euh soyons
sérieux. On se demande parce
que il y a à peine direct
inadmissible
cinquième il fait quoi?
C'est-à-dire que si la Juve
gagne la ligne coton si si le
hein, en Espagne on se souvient
la Ligue Europa et donc ils
seront qualifiés pour la Ligue
des champions via la Ligue
Europa, on va resanctionner la
Juve et on va qualifier Milan
ou l'Inter pour la Ligue des
champions. Mais je vous je
voudrais dire que même en
Espagne il y a eu ça hein, avec
Valence en 2004 justement où on
s'est retrouvé en train de
jouer un championnat avant, à
cette époque c'était dix-huit
parce qu'on a dit bon écoutez
on a d'abord fait qu'ils
descendent et après parce
qu'ils avaient faisaient
maintenant au fait qu'ils
remontent et tout ça bon voilà
donc ces exceptions c'est pas
seulement en Afrique hein ça
existe l'Italie. Mais c'est
mais c'est scandaleux vraiment
euh à un moment et à l'autre.
En tout cas le le le
rendez-vous de ce match ça sera
à huit heures quarante
cinquante ans universel
dimanche soir. Et puis et puis
il y a aussi des choc en
prévision
En Ligue un, le sprint euh
final est lancé. Alors en bas
de classement et on le sait et
on y viendra la semaine
prochaine parce que ça se
bagarre pour descendre ou ne
pas descendre et le premier
club à descendre peut-être au
cours du week-end, on risque de
le connaître et ça pourrait
être le danger. Alors qu'en
tête de classement, alors
hormis le PSG assuré de sa
place européenne et qui quand
même devrait aussi gagner son
onzième titre, eh bien on se
bat encore et on a euh un
nombre de points tellement
réduit entre les uns et les
autres que ces samedi soir, ils
seront les premiers à jouer. Ce
sera le RC Lens qui recevra
l'AS Monaco alors euh ce match
euh allait euh Rémy euh RC Lens
euh avec euh l'AS Monaco eux
ils ont euh deux points d'écart
hein c'est je me trompe pas,
deux points d'écart entre eux,
le troisième et le
soixante-trois. Ce qui fait que
Monaco peut encore prétendre à
une place européenne est-ce que
selon vous on connaît les
statistiques euh je crois
qu'ils ont gagné 14 matchs sur
15 à domicile les soit cette
saison, en tout cas ils n'ont
pas perdu hein. Euh est-ce que
selon vous euh vont réussir à
augmenter leur avantage les
Lensois? Moi je crois.
Sincèrement je crois parce que
ils ont quand même euh une
équipe même si on peut voir que
la dernière prestation fasse
euh à l'aube parisien et
peut-être parce qu'ils ont s'y
étaient en infériorité
numérique. Ouais. Savent aussi
ils m'ont dit que le match a
changé au moment. Ça a changé à
partir de là donc euh quand on
ne peut pas avoir Hum hum. Donc
euh en rouge logique a fait un
très grand match oui. Pardon?
Mais si franchement. des vrais
joueurs et toi tu viens me
parler de quelqu'un que même
les parisiens ne veulent plus
mais attends
moi je crois que aujourd'hui
euh Lens est déjà un bon milieu
de terrain je crois quand même
que d'ailleurs deux sont
nominés au niveau de ce qu'on
peut dire euh les meilleurs
joueurs africains de cette
année donc je crois quand même
si le carton rouge c'est trois
matchs d'exclusion c'est beau.
Oui oui oui et parce qu'il ne
sera pas là et mais je crois
quand même qu'il y aura oui.
Camerounais hein qui va prendre
le relais euh donc je crois
quand même que au regard de
cette équipe de Lens, il y a
beaucoup, ça peut apporter une
certaine lumière alors que au
niveau de Monaco aujourd'hui ça
brille demain on ne sait pas ce
que ça donne, c'est une équipe
très inconstante de telle sorte
que chez moi, même si on donne
n'importe quel joueur à Monaco
parce que quand vous regardez
l'effectif, vous dites quand
même que, mais c'est pas
possible, qu'est-ce qu'ils sont
en train de faire là derrière
finalement tu tu donnes
n'importe quel joueur à Monaco
il devient moyen proverbe
africain, tu donnes la lampe à
un aveugle, ça ne sert à rien.
Xavier , sur ce sur ce choc
quand même entre le troisième
et le quatrième, et ça peut
être, on le sait hein, la
troisième place c'est euh
barrage pour la Ligue des
champions, mais c'est une place
euh donc très importante que
que Monaco a l'habitude
d'occuper. Ouais. Mais Lens Ce
serait surtout que ce serait
mérité parce que ça fait deux
saisons depuis son retour en
Ligue un que Lens est septième.
Donc là, vraiment, il joue pour
jouer euh euh l'Europe. Euh à
la bien sûr est-ce que ils
pourront faire face sur tous
les tableaux, ils pourront pas
faire pire que les clubs
français de cette saison, mais
mais euh c'est vrai que passer
directement d'un club euh de
ligue 1 à un club de Ligue des
champions, il y a il y a un il
y a un énorme euh écart.
D'ailleurs Franck euh le
l'entraîneur disait hier euh si
on a la ligue euh des champions
on sera content, si on a la
Ligue Europa on sera content
aussi. Voilà. Qui sont mais je
pense que le public le public
lensois qui est formidable, il
attend quand même la Ligue des
champions. Donc euh il faut
absolument que Lens ne perde
pas ce match parce que
attention dans euh ils ont
perdu un match avez rappelé à à
Bollaert, c'était contre Nice.
Donc contre une autre équipe de
la Côte d'Azur. Donc il faut
qu'il fasse attention parce que
cette équipe de Monaco elle est
capable de très bonne aussi
donc euh c'est pas gagné sur
quinze. Oui mais c'est pas
gagné pour les Lensois. Marc,
est-ce que la pression dans ce
cas-là euh elle est elle peut
être euh euh négative? Par
rapport à l'enjeu? Hum. Euh je
pense que les Lensois se
battent depuis deux ou trois
saisons, ils pratiquent un jeu
qui est très attrayant, c'est
très intéressant. Je crois que
c'est très bien de voir jouer
Lens. Hum Abdul Sameth, on
prend l'exemple face au PSG,
tout le monde dit oui, c'est
scandaleux, il prend le rouge,
oui il prend l'onge, mais c'est
que peut-être l'enjeu des de
ces grands rendez-vous lui fait
péter un câble. Parce que je
vois pas pourquoi il va
s'essuyer la semelle, il prend
trois matchs, tout le monde est
outré. Ben c'est une agression,
il peut lui casser la jambe.
Donc certes c'est un joueur de
Paris, certes c'est méchant,
mais c'est peut-être l'enjeu et
c'est ça où Lansa doit
progresser, c'est que peut-être
dans la dernière ligne droite
quand il va falloir faire la
différence et et le coach qui
nous explique oui mais si on
navigue Europa Xavier c'est que
la Ligue des champions après
peut-être qu'il est réaliste et
qu'il qu'il pense que derrière
ben son équipe a a que le
niveau de la Ligue Europa.
Alors glissons sur euh
l'Olympico euh parce qu'il y a
un match samedi soir important
et il y a un match qui est très
important. Euh Marc et Olimpico
euh Marseille il avait remporté
au match aller, on a regardé
tout à l'heure hein, c'était un
zéro euh avant la Coupe du
monde si je ne m'abuse. Oui.
Euh comment vous voyez cette
Olympico qui est toujours un
match à part entre Lyon et
Marseille hein, il y a il y a
de d'animosités. C'est toujours
difficile d'aller euh d'aller à
à Lyon, même si euh euh
Marseille reste un petit peu
favori mais depuis quelques
semaines, depuis a récupéré sa
place de dauphin? A récupéré sa
place de dauphin, mais depuis
quelques semaines, euh Lyon
s'est un petit un petit dans le
sens de la marche. Donc, ça va
être un match très loin des
places européennes, mais bon.
Eux, ils jouent presque plus
rien, il y a toujours un espoir
peut-être, mais bon, on peut
toujours rêver, il faudrait
faire un sans-faute jusqu'au
bout et que toutes les équipes,
que ce soit Lille, que ça soit,
se casse un petit peu la
figure, mais ça va être très
difficile pour Marseille, en
sachant que Marseille, il y a
encore beaucoup plus à l'aise
puisqu'ils ont réglé le
problème à la maison en gagnant
face à Troyes. Chancel Memba
est de retour. Vitinia qui joue
devant avec un Alex Sanchez qui
va être au retour, ça peut être
intéressant. Mais Lyon euh sur
ce match-là, Lyon reste le
favori parce que c'est jamais
évident à Lyon d'aller gagner,
mais Marseillais est toujours
capable de faire un petit coup
à l'extérieur. Pour moi, ils
sont capables de le faire. Mais
là, on va voir si l'ensemble du
match ça se passe bien. Un
complément sur ce que nous dit
euh Marc euh Rémy l'Olympico,
vous le voyez comment? Je vois
Marseille. Parce que sommes
déjà à côté des cartons. Je
voudrais être bref pour dire
quand même que au regard de ce
qu'on peut voir comme match
surtout par rapport au fait que
aujourd'hui Marseille n'a pas
droit à l'erreur. Hum hum.
Est-ce que si Marseille
trébuche ça risque d'être très
difficile derrière donc
Marseille aujourd'hui joue sa
survie pour la Ligue des
champions? Marseille il y a un
calendrier très difficile
puisqu'ils vont à Lyon là,
ensuite ils iront à Lens et ils
iront à Lille. Alors la chance
c'est qu'ils marchent mieux à
l'extérieur quà domicile.
C'est magnifique oui absolument
donc on a une fin de
championnat qui nous dit, l'OM
sera deuxième euh grâce à son
expérience. Amen. Amen. C'est
bon. Bon, Marc est content, on
peut aller vers les cartons.
Carton jaune! Un carton jaune.
Oh là là là là! Carton rouge!
Carton rouge! Dans la
conclusion. Carton vert! Rien à
dire. Et tout de suite la
parole est à nos auditeurs euh
et internautes, à nos fidèles,
ceux qui nous suivent et qui
nous envoient leurs cartons
chaque semaine, sélectionnés
par David Finzel. Bonsoir, je
suis Pierre Filler, je vous
suis à Port-au-Prince en Haïti,
j'adresse un carton vert à
Manchester City de Pep
Guardiola pour la qualification
contre le Bayern Munich. On va
jouer contre le Real Madrid en
demi. On va gagner cette
fois-ci contre Rémy N'Gono avec
notre grand cyborg Europe
. Bonjour, je m'appelle l'offre
depuis la RDC. Mon carton est
rouge et c'est pour le vitre
qui est mature. Monsieur a
cordé de tel penalty. Ligue des
champions. Or la ligue des
champions, c'est une
compétition émotionnelle. Il ne
faut pas continuer avec ça. Ça
tue les football. Merci.
Bonjour Radio Foot
International. Moi je m'appelle
Ismaï Abdoulaye, d'origine
centrafricaine. J'habite ici
aux États-Unis. Carton vert,
parti directement à mon club de
choeur Real Madrid. Euh nous
sommes dans le chemin pour
gagner quinzième final de la
ligue des champions. Merci
beaucoup, bonne émission à
vous. Bye bye. Salut tout moi
c'est Amadou Benjamin depuis
moi je donne un carton vert aux
jeunes pépites du Real de
Madrid qui a fait un match
exceptionnel contre Chelsea et
qui a célébré comme le meilleur
joueur du monde Christian
Ronaldo son idole. C'est bien
Kinshasa précisément en RADIO
je donne mon carton vert à peu
près quoi de la pour sa
qualification et aussi son
tactique que j'ai enfin il a
compris pour gagner la Ligue
des champions il faut que je
bonne émission. Bonjour Café de
sports, c'est Roseline depuis
la RADIO j'adresse un carton
vert à l'assimidant qui s'est
qualifié en demi-finale de la
Champions League après Xavier
années mon quartier de sports à
tous. Salut à toute l'équipe du
Café des Sports, je m'appelle
Thomas Biofeld depuis
Libreville au Gabon, je viens
comme ça Xavier au championnat
italien qui a envoyé quatre
clubs en demi-finale
compétitions européennes.
Merci. Salut Radio Foot, c'est
Narcisse Paul. Euh, je vis à le
je donne un carton vert à un
esprit pour le début marqué
hier contre Manchester United.
Deux buts marqués. Donc
vraiment c'est incroyable.
Quand c'est bon, il faut
l'aider. Dites dédicace à toi
champion. Et force à vous.
Bonjour euh, à toute l'équipe
du Café des Sports. Moi c'est
Boyer depuis Lomé. Je veux
donner un carton au ministère
des sports camerounais qui au
lieu de chercher à régler le
problème on en a à l'interne,
c'est-à-dire la fédération, le
ministère ensemble ils vont
trouver une solution pour
qu'ils reviennent en sélection
non le ministère préfère
envoyer le problème en Italie,
écrire un courrier à l'Inter
leur demandant de permettre à
de revenir en sélection. Tout
comme si euh, l'Inter avait une
fois ne serait-ce qu'une seule
fois empêché on en a devenu la
sélection. Carton rouge et
surtout à Rémy N'Golo de leur
appeler le preuve qui dit le
linge sale se lave toujours en
famille, c'est important. Bonne
émission à vous. Bonjour à
tous, c'est Christophe Nico
centrafricain résident à Dakar
au Sénégal. Mon carton il est
vert à l'endroit des fauves de
Bazoubangui. Euh l'équipe de
Centrafrique pour euh leur bon
au niveau de la classification
FOOT et aussi pour cet exploit
lors des phases de la
qualification pour la CAN
prochain en Côte d'Ivoire
contre Madagascar. Euh hommage
à Maf et on est derrière vous
pour la enfin cette cette
qualification qu'on attend tant
au niveau de la phase finale.
Bisous. Bonjour le foot
international, moi c'est depuis
Kinshasa, mon carton est rose.
Rose par rapport à la voix de
madame Ali. Je vous assure que
c'est la première fois que je
l'ai vu, c'était Xavier en tout
cas j'étais époustouflé.
Franchement, ne croyez pas que
la voix de cette impête comme
ça. Comme le dit un proverbe
africain, il faut d'abord voir
une personne avant de les
juger. Check, je voulais, je
vous l'offre beaucoup avec Mais
ici. Alors question, est-ce
qu'il préfère ma voix ou est-ce
qu'il préfère me voir? Alors là
Mais bon, j'espère que c'est
les deux. Surtout euh, il a
dit, avec les enfants. Non,
peut-être, il vous préfère
comme la mère d'enfant. En tout
cas, merci beaucoup et merci
aussi à Roseline, hein, qui
nous a envoyé son carton.
Aujourd'hui, on est toujours
très preneur des supportrices.
Allez, euh, Marc Libra,
justement, je crois que il y a
un petit écho à à ceux qui ont
été donnés. Oui, exact. Moi,
c'est un carton vert, c'est
pour euh, par rapport à à
Clément Turpin. Je vois cette
cabale qu'il y a eu contre lui,
mais en fait, il y est pour
rien. Parce qu'aujourd'hui, il
y a des instances du football
qui donnent, qui dictent des
règles et qui sont obligées
devant donc lui taper dessus
comme de taper sur différents
arbitres, il est en Ligue des
champions, il doit appliquer la
règle. La règle aujourd'hui
elle n'est plus du tout au goût
du jour des défenseurs ultra
modernes. Peut-être à mon
époque ça aurait pu exister,
mais aujourd'hui ça ne peut pas
exister. On nous explique, on
doit se jeter, ça effleure
bêtement, il suit la loi. Donc
il y a une loi, il faut changer
cette loi et très rapidement
parce qu'autrement on va s'en
prendre à des hommes alors que
c'est pas les hommes. C'est les
instances derrière qui font
n'importe quoi, qui sont assis
dans des fauteuils et qui je
pense n'ont jamais joué au
football. Quand il y a main, il
y a carton rouge, quel que soit
on a bien dû couper, il le fait
pas exprès. Mais bien sûr. Mais
ça est rappelé eh ben le
règlement il dit ça, ben vous
riez un feu rouge eh ben on on
va pas vous dire, ben non je
vous laisse passer. Bon ben là
c'est pareil. Et celui de Sadio
Mané est très rigolo aussi
puisqu'il sortait, le ballon
sortait, tout allait sortir.
Ouais. Sur la ligne de touche
grâce à la barre. Ouais voilà.
On Xavier arrêtons de de taper
sur les arbitres et surtout sur
lui par rapport à vous avez un
proverbe? Non. J'en ai pas.
Désolé vous m'avez pris de
cours. Alors carton jaune à
quelqu'un qui est dans une
sélection où on met le jaune
d'asile. Euh jaune aussi. Ah
oui. Ah oui. Mais je ne
comprends pas. On nous a vanté
ce type-là comme ayant un sens
de but, comme le Brésilien qui
pouvait cartonner et tout et
tout. Mais je me rends quand
même compte que le gars a
réussi l'exploit en Première
ligue. D'être zéro but marqué,
non il a marqué trois buts.
De
hors-jeu, il ne parvient
même pas à se positionner sur
un stade de football. Et
cependant on constate quand
même que dans la sélection du
du brésilienne, eh bien Richard
avait son ex titulaire pendant
que Rodrigo comme voit au Real
Madrid briller est complètement
euh même super bicyclette
pendant la Coupe du monde. Ah
oui oui la Coupe du monde. Mais
c'est c'est c'est un problème
africain qui dit on ne saura
jamais le mystère de l'homme
qui a tué le lièvre avec la
**** Euh Xavier c'est compliqué
pour euh Richard Alison à
Tottenham. Euh carton vert moi,
carton vert, un joueur de Cadix
que vous ne connaissiez
probablement pas Jérémy
Ledesma, le gardien argentin.
Alors il a pris quatre buts
contre Barcelone mais c'est pas
pour ça qu'il a un carton vert.
C'est tout simplement parce
quà un moment du match, eh
bien tout d'un coup il a pris
l'initiative de sprinter
jusqu'au banc de touche, de
récupérer un défibrillateur
pour sauver quelqu'un qui est
en train de faire un malaise
dans les tribunes du stade de
Café . Et son geste a permis à
cette personne d'être évacuée
vers l'hôpital et d'être donc
sauvée. Bravo à lui. Alors
après, il a pas tellement
récompense puisqu'il a quand
même pris quatre buts du Barça
qui est allé gagner à Calice.
Bon, en tout cas c'est un hum
un carton très humain.
Frédéric? Un carton vert pour
l'entraîneur du Clermont Foot,
Pascal Gastien. 59 ans, il
vient d'être renouvelé pour un
an de plus, il est arrivé à
Clermont en 2017. Euh on entend
pas beaucoup parler de lui, il
fait son boulot, il les a fait
monter en ligue un. Cette
journée, clairement, 1neuvième
budget de ligue 1 qui est
onzième, quarante-trois points
déjà assuré de se maintenir en
grande partie grâce à Pascal
Cassien. Le carton de Radio
Foot va à deux supporters qui
avaient pris de la hauteur
pendant le match de euh ben il
y a un problème de maillot, ils
sont pas copains dans la vie.
Voilà. Hein porter les couleurs
de l'OM et l'autre porte les
couleurs du PSG et les deux
vous les voire Barça et ils ne
sont pas tombés de l'arbre,
c'était juste au-dessus du
terrain et c'était très drôle.
Et on se quitte avec cette euh
image qui fait parfois plaisir
hein la passion foot. On se dit
à la semaine prochaine, merci
Merci.